I hope everybody who had a long
weekend had a good long weekend.
We are back and we must dove right into it.
Last week, I laid out for you one framework
for looking at the polling that was relatively
optimistic. And that framework essentially was
Joe Biden is beating Trump nationally by more
than Hillary was beating Trump nationally at
this point four years ago. And Joe Biden is doing
quite well in some important swing states. Today,
I want to give you an alternative perspective,
which gives us reason for caution and for care.
And it's a different framing of the same data
and in the states likely to be decision makers.
The reality is that Joe Biden is not doing
as well as Hillary Clinton was doing at this
point in 2016. Now, let me be very clear as we get
into this. I'm not telling you which framework is
correct. Ultimately, there is a reason why we do
the voting. We don't just say these are the polls.
So that's the election. The election is the actual
voting. And this is merely a point of perspective.
It can be at the same time true that Joe Biden
is doing better nationally and in some states
than Hillary was in 2016 while trailing in other
states relative to Hillary. It doesn't tell us
who will win. Only are voting, tells us who and
who will win. So the conclusion is, of course,
we have to vote. But let's look at the data.
We're going to compare three important states,
Michigan, Pennsylvania and Wisconsin. Those
are three states that Trump won in 2016.
And we're going to look at how Hillary was
doing. Twenty two days before the election
compared to how Biden is doing. So let's start
in Michigan. In Michigan, at this point in 2016,
Hillary was winning by ten point seven.
While today Biden is winning by only
seven. So Hillary's lead at this point in
Michigan was bigger than Biden's today. And
what happened in the end in Michigan? Trump
won by zero point three. In Pennsylvania,
we had Joe Biden. Today, we have Joe Biden
today with essentially the same lead that
Hillary had in 2016. It's a difference of less
than half a point. And in the end, in 2016,
Donald Trump won in Pennsylvania by just
under one point. Then we have Wisconsin.
And in Wisconsin, Joe Biden currently leads by six
point one. That is a smaller lead than Hillary's
at this point in 2016. And again, that is a state
that ultimately was won by Donald Trump. Why does
this matter? It matters because even if Biden gets
a larger popular vote victory than Donald Trump
on the wings of massive victories in large blue
states like California, New York, as examples,
he can still lose electorally if he loses these
states. Case in point, if we look at average
polling right now and look at a sort of consensus
map in which we give Joe Biden, Nevada and North
Carolina, which we don't know, that Biden will
win, but give Biden Nevada, give Biden North
Carolina. And we simply leave out for the moment.
The three states we're talking about and Florida.
That gets Joe Biden 257 electoral votes. That's 13
shy of the number he needs. If in that scenario,
Biden wins Michigan or Pennsylvania or any
two of the three states, Michigan, Wisconsin,
Pennsylvania, then Biden no longer needs Florida
at all. And Biden wins. But if Joe Biden ends up
losing these three states that we're talking
about, Wisconsin, Michigan and Pennsylvania,
all of a sudden the entire election
comes down to Florida and Florida alone,
which did not go well in 2016 for Hillary
Clinton. Now, of course, you can say, come on,
David. The polling won't be wrong in all of
those states. I certainly hope not. But remember,
the polling tightened in the last
two weeks. The exercise today is
if we look at Biden today in Wisconsin, Michigan
and Pennsylvania, compared to Hillary 22 days out
four years ago, Biden is not doing as well as
Hillary was doing at that point. Of course,
the polling tightened. So the point here is
when it's this close, the confidence does
nothing for us. We just have to know that
these states look okay for Biden right now.
They looked better for Hillary in 2016 and she
lost those states and subsequently the election,
which is why our conclusion from all of this
beautiful academic exercise here. But the
conclusion is we can do nothing other than vote
in every state as if it's 50/50. And our vote,
my vote, your vote could be the vote that decides
your state. If you game it out. Is the only
rational approach to this election. I hope that
is the approach you are going to be up adopting.